trouble brewing in Democrat land Kamala
Harris no longer on speaking terms with
Elizabeth Warren and sending Liz
straight to voicemail after the senator
dodged a 2024 endorsement
should Kamala Harris be that his choice
a second time around you know I I really
want to defer to what makes Biden
comfortable on his team I've known
Kamala for a long time I like Kamala we
go way back but they need they have to
be a team in my sense is they are I
don't mean that by suggesting I think
there are any problems I think they are
no problems at all that I just bring up
Warren walked back that comment but
Kamala hasn't been able to laugh it off
the senator has reportedly been trying
to get a hold of the VP to bury the
hatchet
but over a month later Harris is
refusing to budge but don't worry Kamala
you'll always have the view to tout your
accomplishments
I think there's some concern about just
the lack of a policy accomplishments
that she's made as vice president I'm
surprised that there's concern I think
it has a lot to do with this she's a
black woman black women get everything
done we've saved this country's
democracy she's obviously amazing but
what specifically but
the inflation reduction act I mean
she's the face of Roe v Wade I mean the
list goes on and on that's the best
but the damn pile up doesn't end there
Joe Biden taking off the squad at AOC
after approving an eight billion dollar
oil drilling project in Alaska played
tweeting this disastrous decision will
have devastating consequences on our
planet front line communities and
Wildlife all right Dana little thought
experiment right now there's a Subway
it's late at night a subway car just Liz
and Kamala which one gets out alive
yes
so um one of the things about the Kamala
Harris piece is that it's not
conservatives who are criticizing her
they don't have to yeah this is coming
from Democrats in fact there was an
article yesterday that said there's a
lot of Democrats concerned about the
piling on against Kamala Harris because
what that what that could mean so we
just sit back and watch all of this and
we learn a little bit more about what
the Democrats think of her and they are
concerned 80 of Democrats don't want
Biden to run again and they're concerned
that the conversation is going to turn
to well if people are concerned about
him not running again and they talk
about his age and then you talk about
the inevitable which is if she were to
take over does this become a contest in
2024 between a Kamala Harris candidacy
in theory and whoever the Republican
nominee is that's a concern I have some
advice I would like to impart that's
what makes this show so great yes so
when somebody has insulted you yes and
they get called out on it and they
apologize in public and then they try to
call you I have what I call the three
call practice rule the first call you
send a voicemail the second call you ask
your assistant to take a message and the
third call you take and on that call is
where your political instincts should
kick in that might not happen here but
let's say the third call you take the
call and then you get leverage and you
use it to your advantage and you get her
to get Warren to do something that you
need her to do or that you want her to
do whatever that might be you could say
I need to go and do this fundraiser for
me I need you to take over the Border
because I'm not actually doing that you
actually need something to happen yes
you could ask her to do anything but
that so that's my rule anybody if you
get dissed and they call you wait three
times on the third call take the call
that's right what if they call you right
before the five though then it starts
over right it goes back to zero no I
think you could call and say oh no
that's a great one because then you
could say sorry I missed your call
I was on a live show called the five
it's very popular you might have heard
of it yes that drives me crazy Jesse are
you mad that Barry the hatchets or even
used today and you can't use it on your
show I already used it last week so I
like what Dan is thinking with the
emotional blackmail the silent treatment
but do you really need Kamala talking to
you I mean if Kamala gives you the
silent treatment so what it's not like
she has a ton of Leverage and what is
she going to use Liz Warren for I don't
know if Liz Warren is that useful of a
person now if I were Kamala I would be
upset that she said that as an
emotionally attuned man if someone said
basically you're done then I don't know
if I would take that person's call I
might never pick up on the third ring
okay so but that doesn't matter because
Liz Warren is not as influential as
people think she's unnecessary what you
need are donors to love you and you're
right because it's the age factor for
Biden and the Kamala confidence factor
is the same thing and if you talk about
one you're talking about the other and
vice versa so that's the Democrats
problem and if the view is blindly
following Kamala that tells you
something she could not
spontaneously name a single
accomplishment she started rattling off
titles that she'd held 10 20 years ago
and then she started naming things that
Joe Biden signed that Kamala had nothing
to do with that is the best defense they
had for Kamala Harris right now and
that's a problem but right now we're in
this awkward stage where Joe hasn't
announced and you've seen like this
momentum start building about them
trying to gently pull Kamala off the
ticket and then now you're seeing
pushback from
women and black women especially about
don't you dare pull my black woman off
the ticket and that's really where we
are right now and it's I think it's the
donor's next move they're up um Jessica
is the time for the peace pipe
yes I understand
um I love this I think that this shows
that Kamala Harris has a backbone and
that she has
some of that sassiness that existed
throughout her career why people liked
her in the hearings when Bill Barr was
testifying to get confirmed as attorney
general the sparring
um she has Vibe right now and she hasn't
had Vibe this entire time people have
just been attacking her saying what's
she doing she's you know the Zarina of
the Border she's never down there right
um you know she was the face of the Roe
v Wade conversation what does that
really mean I actually think that meant
a lot but I can understand how people
would sit there and say well it's not
her name on any of this which is frankly
a problem that all vice presidents face
right Joe Biden has looking back at his
eight years as vice president one thing
that I would say was really Joe Biden's
and that was getting gay marriage passed
but otherwise and he had that was into
his second term that was 2015 when that
happened after 50 years of being against
it but that's okay he had an epiphany in
high school yeah that's true that's a
lie
so I think that this is actually good
for her because it sends a signal out
into the public that she's not just
going to be walked all over and she's
certainly not going to be walked all
over by somebody who wanted the job that
she ended up getting and when Elizabeth
Warren says I didn't mean to say that
this woman eviscerated Mike Bloomberg
ruined his presidential campaign I think
of 43 seconds Elizabeth Warren does not
misspeak and that doesn't mean that I
think that Kamala Harris is God's gift
to the vice presidency but it means that
she knew what she was doing and that
Kamala knows what she's doing I agree
with you take the third call because
there is something about the caucus of
female Democrats from the Senate they
have like they have a thing together and
I think that it's important to hold that
up and to have the support but I like
that she showed that she wasn't going to
be pushed around like just not returning
her call that's a low bar for
achievement it's the lead store we're
talk everyone is talking about it
they're talking about it across you know
a harder comeback would have been
something like well I'm real indian and
she's not yeah
that was good you know Emily I think if
we were going to summarize what Jessica
said it would be that Kamala hasn't
expressed any value behind her identity
is that what you were trying to say yeah
[Laughter]
but she hasn't been able to get Beyond
why she was chosen that's exactly right
and remember after she assumed the vice
presidency I think within a year there
was sort of an assembly gathered of
democratic strategists and people who
had worked with her that they were
trying to craft a counter narrative to
the fact that they were she was being
eviscerated rightly so in the media for
not having to accomplished some anything
um and one of the top strategists said
look she has more experience in elected
office than several past presidents and
vice presidents she said she's being
held to an unreasonable standard if that
were true if she's so experienced why is
there nothing to show for it why was it
simply the box that was checked that got
her to where she's been because no one
can cite any accomplishments or
achievements from being a D.A or an
attorney general or a senator
um I've literally managed performance uh
in performance enhancement plans for
federal attorneys and federal employees
where they did less than she has and
she's being lauded she's been called the
face of Roe v Wade she's absolutely
failed in everything that she's been
assigned to and I have to say I think
that part of that narrative that you're
crafting I love the idea but I think
it's part of a false interpretation of
it I remember her questions for example
when uh just before director of Pompeo
the CIA when he was going through his
nomination process her questions were
absurd that Pit Bull Association with a
prosecutor to me there was no substance
it was that knee-jerk sort of Grudge
that we're having because to me
forgiveness is divine I would rather
have a graceful vice president that has
some intellectual substance than one
that simply
shuts off do not disturb and expects me
to respect her for it well I think I I
just feel bad that I didn't come up with
that joke oh I stole it from Corolla oh
damn you hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else